[Music]
filmmaking
is one of the few tools that could open
minds into other ideas people's cultures
stories connect us and help us to
process our human experience it engages
all these senses and of course in mind
we need to tell stories to show that we
can grow and emerge into a future that
is brighter and better
we all
have a role to play in ensuring that our
future is sustainable i think filmmaking
today is important because we need some
new ants i think people definitely need
worlds to jump into to put themselves in
the shoes of somebody else i believe
that now is the time for people from all
walks of life to bring ideas to life
[Music]
in the world today it's important for
more diverse voices to be heard being
able to relate stories and create worlds
i feel like it reflects something
greater
um
the problem can be specific but the
struggle is universal mostly try to
deliver the whole to our daily life and
i think that is the power of film
i think cinema is not just a form of
escape but also incredibly powerful in
raising awareness filmmaking it is
important it will continue to be an
important part of our
lives i think it's very important to
share
the hopeful message to the world and
hopefully i can change something
hi everyone i'm david rubin president of
the academy of motion picture arts and
sciences
welcome to the 48th student academy
awards celebration
last year at this event i said that i
hoped most of all that 2020 would be our
first and last virtual celebration
well what i meant to say was
that i truly hope 2021 would be our
second and last virtual celebration
like all presidents i reserve the right
to correct the official record
but the fact that we are not together in
person does not diminish one bit the
importance of what brings us together
today we celebrate artists whose work
whose vision whose sheer talent make all
of us at the academy excited for the
future of cinema
like last year our judges and panels
chose from over 1400 submissions
1404 to be exact coming from student
filmmakers at 336 schools in countries
around the globe and like last year
there are up to three awards in each
category gold silver and bronze
and like every year none of this would
have been remotely possible without the
485 academy members who volunteered
their time to judge this year's entrance
each and every one of them was paying it
forward
and having had a sneak peek of the work
of this year's winners i can assure you
our winners are already paying it right
back with their vision
their imagination
and their daring
and we are the lucky recipients of that
gift
and now it's my great honor to introduce
our host whose work i've admired in the
hunger games the darkest minds the hate
you give
the eddie and if you haven't seen her
sing the anonymous ones a new song in
dear evan hansen
just wait
an amazing young artist and activist
please welcome amandla stanberg
thank you david for that kind
introduction
and for inviting me to be a part of this
great annual tradition my role is to let
you all in on a wonderful surprise and
to take you behind the scenes when this
year's winners logged onto zoom for what
they thought was a simple interview for
the competition
only to receive a special surprise from
some of their heroes and our icons the
gift of learning that they were 2021
student academy award winners
so let's start in the narrative category
these winners never dreamed that when
they logged on to zoom they'd be hearing
the biggest news of their young careers
from a young director whose
accomplishments continue to grow
the director of diary of a teenage girl
can you ever forgive me
and a beautiful day in the neighborhood
a storyteller who has always tackled
inconvenient truths and uncomfortable
realities
marielle heller
let's all check out these amazing
moments when they got the news of their
achievement from mario
hello hi i'm sean i'm director of the
student academy awards how does it feel
to be a finalist it's really
mind-boggling
the day i got the news i just like
screamed for her for like 30 seconds
straight so there's a an aspect to this
conversation that i didn't mention
uh so i invited a special guest it's my
pleasure to introduce you to marielle
heller
oh my god hi oh my gosh
i'm actually here to tell you that your
film has won the bronze medal in the
narrative competition
oh my gosh congratulations
noah know heaven has won the student
academy award
congratulations ruthie i mean
congratulations to all of us
my name is christy hoy and i'm a recent
graduate of the ucla mfa directing
program what's your name
no law no heaven tells a story of the
life of a man named ming as he navigates
his sexual identity in hong kong's
notorious kowloon walled city my parents
i want to give them a good life what
about you
i was really inspired from the story of
the kowloon walled city it's been the
center of fascination for a lot of
dystopic sci-fi
but this was a real place that was
inhabited by real people
i was studying to be a comic book artist
and so it was something that i always
wanted to do is to bring
my ideas from 2d into 3d it's not quite
surrealistic it's kind of like reality
plus they all help to bolster really the
story and what the character's going
through
i come from two generations of
immigrants i think making this film
definitely did help me
in my journey to figuring out what my
identity is with my films i want to be
able to just reach out to those that
feel other and tell them that it's okay
i feel other and we can be other
together
it's just absolutely mind-blowing to
have won i just can't believe it i'm
just so happy
i would like to dedicate this award to
my mama jude hung who passed earlier
this year thank you so so much
and i'm actually here to let you know
that you have won the silver medal in
the narrative competition what
oh my
god my name is akonsha krazzinski i'm a
graduate of columbia college chicago and
my film is close ties to home country
could you pronounce your
name is it a a [ __ ] shot oh it's
pronounced a concha just think of a
conch shell i've got one of those
somewhere i think the film is quite
literally lifted from my own life i'm
originally from india i grew up in saudi
arabia and i'm an immigrant and i'm also
a dog walker i'm actually currently dog
sitting and then my sister's us visa was
rejected in 2015 and i thought why not
combine these two into one project my
intention with making the film was to
raise some awareness about the very
broken system that is our immigration
system
when i left she was
14 years old
and
now she's 25
and
i will always remember her as a 14 year
old i feel like
i want to tell stories about women who
have lived in places that we're not
talking about i'm originally from india
but i grew up in saudi arabia where
little girls aren't even allowed to like
go outside and play like they have to be
doing everything indoors so my two
hobbies were reading and watching movies
and it was it was it wasn't just a form
of escape it was almost a form of
survival
winning a student academy award is great
because i had to really explain to my
mom what that even means she's like wait
what academy and i'm just like you know
the oscars and she's like are you gonna
get a statue and i was like no i'm gonna
get a medal and so she thinks it's a
scam that's okay i'm okay with that my
brand is scammy as hell so i think it
fits it fits perfectly
i'm actually here to tell you that your
film has won the gold medal in the
narrative competition what
congratulations
oh my goodness oh my gosh
my name is pumi marari i am the writer
director of laguchonilanga which means
when the sun sets i graduated from
chapman university
my film is about a young black nurse
living in 1985 apartheid south africa
she has to face her worst fears when she
discovers that her younger baby brother
who is an activist has gone missing
the film is inspired by an incident that
happened in my mother's life in the
1980s in south africa she saw her
younger brother getting abducted by
apartheid police and she had to figure
out what to do about it and i was really
moved by the story and the way my mom
told it because she told it in passing
as if it meant nothing
she didn't believe that she was a hero
she believed that she was just doing
what had to be done
and i was curious about the kind of
situations in life that caused us to
unleash that inner power
i think a lot of people who have seen
films about this era in south africa
have seen it from a very sort of grand
perspective of iconic images i
think there's so many more personal
family stories it's so meaningful that
myself as an african woman could even
win a student academy award and that
somebody in the u.s would care about my
story it's just
it's very surreal and it's such an honor
if you dream of playing in the nba
imagine meeting lebron james
but if your home court is the world of
animation
there is no greater icon than the only
person in history to win three oscars
for best animated feature
nine time academy award nominee and the
chief creative officer of pixar the
legendary pete doctor
and for this year's big reveal to our
animation winners
the doctor was in let's take a look
i get to tell you that you are the
bronze medal winner
in the animation awards congratulations
oh my gosh
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
i don't know what to say
academy student awards i am the bronze
winner
[Applause]
currently in the period we're in we need
a lot of hope we need a lot of faith and
we need people to trust and lean on
slumber with snakes is about two 11 year
old african american boys who lived in
1921 and they happened to run into a
white woman who thought they were trying
to rob her
this ensued a giant racist mom who
chased them out of the town and one of
the boys gets trapped in a snake cave
overnight and he doesn't know at all
what happens to his friend this story
came from bob and marsha hollins they
adopted my father into their family and
therefore they raised me as the
grandchild bob is the man who he is
today because of his dad who is slim and
the main character of this film
for so long it's been a verbal story i
was trying to capture the essence of who
these people were in the story and as i
went along it all just became so real
and now it's a physical story other
people can see it and
we can share with people who are outside
of our family
it's really a message of love the main
hero chooses
to not take revenge and not to hold on
to bitterness instead he chooses to
choose love
and that's how marsha and bob got
together
winning
a student academy award it blows my mind
away not many students are given this
opportunity as soon as they leave school
and i just feel so
i just feel so honored
i have the pleasure of telling you that
you have won the silver medal
in the animation category
congratulations
thank you so much
[Music]
my film is about when the entire british
royal family dies and the queen's corgi
is next in line for the throne he has to
take on that responsibility and it
doesn't exactly go his way
really wanted to do a story that
reflected me and who i am as a person
which is just
very goofy nuking france wasn't exactly
a popular thought in the pitch room they
had a couple issues with that one for
every issue that i had i was just like
i'll figure it out because i really just
was so
stubborn i really wanted to tell
something that left people with an
impression of it whether it was good or
bad
that was kind of my biggest takeaway was
i'm gonna make them remember this piece
[Applause]
as an animator i feel like it's
difficult to sneak into
the world of directing i want to try to
make that leap and not only present
myself as an animator but someone with
ideas who
has new stories to tell and new thoughts
to share
winning a student academy award helps me
present myself to myself and to show
like i did this i am capable of doing
this something that meant a lot like who
i want to be in my journey and where i
want to go
i'd like to thank the academy for this
huge honor i'd like to thank my composer
sound designers and my voice actor for
bringing the story to life
if any of you
have an idea i managed to get a student
academy award
by nuking a country
so i think that you can tell whatever
kind of story you want
[Music]
i actually have a fun job in addition to
just saying hi because i'm the one that
gets to tell you sujin that you have won
the gold medal in the animation category
really
congratulations it's not like a hidden
camera thing or something
oh my gosh thank you so much
the main topic that i have been pursuing
through my artistic practice is an
investigation of social marginalization
exclusion and oppression that exist on
their power structure unforgotten
depicts the tragic historical event of
four late korean women who suffered as
the sexist slaves during world war ii
under japanese military units this
comfort woman issue has been very
important issue in my country when i
watch other film about this topic most
of them they are too much focusing on
visualizing how violently those women
are sexually abused i think that could
be another visual violence to those
victims
this joke led me to explore and also
present somehow alternative way to
visualize the violence and the summons
painful memory and traumas in film
i hope audience can focus on their will
of the resistance their internal
strengths giving the testimonies to the
world so that woman will never be again
sexually sacrifice it during the war
time most importantly i always try to
express the resilient human energy
against such injustice because i really
believe we can overcome
those injustice or painful memories or
sadness when we briefly visualize it
[Music]
of course my hidden heroes are my
parents although they actually cannot
understand what i'm doing let's say
but they're always supporting what i'm
doing what i want to do
winning student academy award is the
most meaningful achievements i can get
as a person who studied animation in
school i felt frustrated a lot in the
process of learning it but eventually i
realized
the outcome is always meaningful i
really truly appreciate that student
academy award gave me the gold medal
especially for the most meaningful
projects for me which is unforgotten
[Music]
i invited a special guest to join us
theo caillou marion it's a pleasure to
introduce you to pete doctor oh my god
it's great to meet you all and um i
actually get another fun job which is i
get to tell you all that you three have
won the gold medal in the international
animation category
whoa
thank you
lessons louis lewis shoes
uh
a north artist literally he will
introduce himself in a new school and we
will discover his specific manner to
we want to use this a very specific lens
but actually to talk about everybody
like this kind of social life it's of
primitive struggle actually it's all in
us
demons
in animation is really you think like an
artist but you actually work like a
soldier
so um it is amazing that i found these
two
mario and there to fight with me one
frame at a time
today
[Music]
my mom my dad
and all my friends who support me back
home in hong kong
[Music]
our composer is
[Music]
foreign
i hope someday we can meet maybe in in
france yeah
when you want
whatever you want
one of documentary filmmaking's most
brilliant rising stars nan fu wang has
never shied away from the toughest
subjects
her debut work in hooligan sparrow
brought the story of sexual assault in
china out of the shadows
even when it meant suffering government
surveillance herself
this year's documentary winners address
subjects as dark and deeply personal as
the impact of suicide and as horrifying
as human rights abuses
so who could be more inspirational than
non-fu wong who has walked in their
shoes to bring them the news of their
breakthrough at the student academy
awards
[Music]
hi diana how are you i'm great how are
you great it's great to meet you and i'm
here today to tell you that your film
has won the bronze medal in the
documentary category oh my
god i'm not gonna cry but i'm just
holding back tears because this is so
exciting
so not just the name explores the stigma
and racial bias experienced by african
americans with unique sounding names as
well as the historical origin of these
names in america basically this idea
came because i struggled with my own
name i took the apostrophe out and the
capital o out because my teachers were
just shortening my name and i would fill
out paperwork and forms and they were
rejected all the time and i started to
meet other black americans who had
unique names and the struggles that they
had with those names and i felt inclined
to
take a deeper dive into the topic making
this film allowed me to not only explore
black culture but cultures from all over
the world i
had the pleasure of speaking to
so many amazing people
that i started to question myself and my
identity and
my name and why i made the choices that
i made to shorten my name
my name is the anna young stephens
nice to meet you filmmaking is the
greatest art on earth to me personally
it documents what is happening at a
particular moment and it tells the
stories of phenomenal people that have
graced this world there's something to
looking at something so cinematic and
seeing
an image come across your screen that
shows some form of representation or
seeing someone that looks like you in a
story and imagining yourself in that
world couldn't have done it without
my fabulous crew
of all talented people i can always
think about this art that i made and
it's gonna always be a constant reminder
about this journey that i took with
other people going through the same
situation the bonds that i've formed
it'll always be a constant reminder that
i am enough and that my name is enough
now i have a student academy award and i
feel so stinking happy
uh i am here to tell you that your film
has won the silver medal in the
documentary category congratulations
this is an interview right
well
it was an interview now it's not anymore
[Laughter]
i'm already happy
my film is about a man and he's a
minority in china returned to his
hometown to coach the kids in basketball
because he got inspired by his icon kobe
bryant and this film is also my tribute
to kobe bryant and basketball which
inspired me to make this film i think
filmmaking is trying to put pieces
together and to make a new meaning i
thought it was a documentary about
basketball but it turns out to be
something that is more about
their life
and i try to expose this minority's life
which is underrepresented so we are
using sichuan dialect not mandarin in
this film so that is another reason i
think language is very important way to
to gain the trust from the subjects
[Music]
i think student academy awards gives me
a confirmation that i made a great job
that just also gives me a platform that
i can show this great job to other
people i think this chance really you
know from the best film institution and
we are all dreaming for to give us
chance to share our works and to inspire
more people i want to thank the village
the kids
and
your passion for basketball i want to
thank my family
nyu professor marshall rock my
classmates dude75 my composers and
kobe this film is for you you're still
inspiring the world even to mountain
village that is seven thousand miles
away from los angeles
hi
hi kristen
hello i'm such a
fan of your work and how amazing and
nuanced all of your films are i am here
to tell you that your film has won
the gold medal oh my god adventuring
category
this is so cool
even though
i had grown up in california i lived
here almost all of my life i still had
no idea how much agriculture is produced
in this state our industrial food chain
relies on people like individual people
and families and these individual
insects i certainly spoke with
a lot of beekeepers over the phone
people were sort of curious and thought
what is this crazy girl doing why why
does she want to film me doing my job
it's probably boring it's always so
fulfilling to have people trust you
enough to tell their story and to do it
on camera and also just just to learn
about about what their life is like and
what their backgrounds are like and why
they believe the things that they do so
this is my beekeeper's jacket to
minimize the amount of stinging that
happens and i couldn't see the camera
while i was filming through the mesh
so i had to get a covered face shield
and modify this and cut a hole in the
mesh and sew the shield into it so what
i hope audiences take away from this
film is the realization that
we all
have a role to play in ensuring that our
future is sustainable and that our
current world
and the systems that we've set up to
produce energy and food and all of these
things that we've decided are necessary
is not sustainable my documentary won
the student academy award
i never expected this nomination i never
expected this win and i think it really
is just validation that pursuing stories
that i think are important and that
matter to me when that authenticity
comes through
it it makes it matter to a wider
audience
milo i'd like you to meet nan fu wong hi
milo nice to meet you hi
nice to meet you what a pleasant
surprise i'm here today to tell you that
you have won the gold medal in the
international documentary category
what
congratulations
oh my god
my name is milo haifers and i made the
graduation film why didn't you stay for
me at the dutch film academy
okay
i'm actually
[Music]
in my film i'm meeting four children who
lost a parent by suicide
and i made the film because i also lost
my mom by suicide when i was young and
in the film i also share my own story
through animation
so that took some vulnerability
it took us a long time to to animate it
i just wanted to convey my feelings and
thoughts without making it literal
it gave some breathing space
because the interviews with the children
were so intense that it was nice to zoom
out sometimes and be in a less realistic
world
and animation is perfect for that
[Music]
i would like my audience to know what
it's like to lose a parent by suicide
because i think
a lot of people have an opinion about
suicide but it's different when it's
your own parents
winning the award for me is just very
surreal it's like some crazy child
fantasy or something that has come true
but i think it's even more special for
the children because it's really a
recognition that their story should be
told around the globe you know not only
here in the netherlands that it deserves
a bigger audience and that they can be
proud of it that they dared to do it
oh
well can i be honest
i drink a ton of this white suburban mom
drink diet coke something crunchy
and salty well
a glass of wine that they can't korean
soul food i think my ideal stress relief
food is chocolate ice cream rice crispy
treats all day every day
um i just want a hot shower at the end
of the day
comedy
and the deepest and saddest drama you
can find on earth did they say that
comedy plus time equals
life or something no i think that
yeah coming off age drama for now
thriller and drama because i always mean
well but i end up
messing up a lot i think the phrase is
truth
tragedy plus time
induction empire new york yeah
something very melancholic the filler
you saw
a little bit like not super high budget
i wanted to say horror but like i'm not
i'm afraid of horror films so i don't
know what the phrase is but
but my life is somewhere in that phrase
i hope we don't use this
so yeah this is like the most difficult
question ever for me to answer i gotta
get back to them like three to five
business days
of my life
it would be like about a man trying to
get the sun out of his eyes
not realizing that he has his hat on
backwards
pushing boundaries in varsity or french
asgar farhadi has made a mark defined
convention and widening the lens of
social realism
turning heads from tehran
to tinseltown
this year he joins us to honor our own
cultural pioneers
the young person brave and bold enough
to plant their flag in a diverse milieu
we call alternative and experimental
film
so let's have a look
it's a pleasure to introduce you to
asgar for hubby hello oh my god i adore
your films
thank you
oh you won the gold model in alternative
experimental oh my god i didn't know
that
congratulations i
am glad that i
i decided to wear a blazer
hi my name is hao jo and my film is
called frozen out
this film is not about like you know
traditional narrative telling story
it's more
about what i want to say to my family
and what i have experienced here i grew
up in a very rural area in china because
of the pandemic i couldn't see my family
like face to face since i come to the us
to study so i just want to make a you
know short piece to connect the visual
image
that i captured from my hometown and to
where i am right now here in iowa
so all i could say
there's no better
medium i think for expressing my
interest and stories and
the
themes that matter
i'm the winner of the alternative
experimental session
we're so proud of you and to be the
first university of iowa to receive this
student academy award tremendous
the student academy awards are the most
significant and iconic thing award
for students so i feel grateful and
seen
here's something that i learned about
asgar
he is in a rarefied crowd of directors
who have won the oscar for international
film more than once
which makes him the perfect person to
present the awards to this year's
student academy award winners for
international narrative
how are you are you ready for the good
news of course please tell me the pros
model narrative international goes to
solar pashtun amazing thank you so much
how do you feel though i'm very very
honored and happy especially to hear it
from you as well you have no idea how
much your films mean to me thank you
it's very important moment for you enjoy
of this you guys made my day and my year
probably my career as
well thank you
my name is salar
i'm the director of short film bad omen
my film is about an afghan war widow
based in kabul afghanistan the story is
about her being an in-house tailor that
needs to buy prescription glasses in
order to keep her job the film is very
personal to me because just like the
lead character bree my mother is also a
widow i was 11 years old my mother was
28 when she lost her husband so i have
firsthand witness the harsh realities
that the widows have to go through back
home in kabul afghanistan
i'm hoping that the audience can realize
that afghan women are resilient they're
strong they're powerful they have been
providing for their families
i was always interested in cinema where
i come from cinema filmmaking these are
not very respected
filmmaking it is important it will
continue to be important because
regardless of what kind of cinema you
enjoy
one way or the other we do end up either
learning something from cinema or
disappearing in the cinema and
forgetting about the reality of our
day-to-day life at the end of the day i
want to make films that are meaningful
because there are so many stories that
needs to be told
to my cast and crew especially nikolai
parvez vareshna and everyone involved
thank you so much for going above and
beyond to make this film a possibility
yeah i would like to dedicate this award
to the ones this film is about to the
southless and stronger one mothers you
are the real superheroes
hello simon happy to meet you hi how are
you i have a very good news for you the
silver medal international narrative
goes to
simon
denda
it's fabulous it's what i always dreamt
about being recognized by the academy
it's it's
just amazing this is very important
congratulations thank you thank you very
much
my name is simon denda and my film is a
diesel
edisa is about an european
representative and she's going to
campaign for humanitarian aid in the
north of kenya but her presence in the
region causes a tragic incident
edesa is a very personal story for me
because i have a five-year-old son and i
asked myself how would i react if
something like this happened to me so i
tried to dig into this with the film and
try to show the layers in between
i think filmmaking is very important we
are storytellers we are narrators and we
can tell stories about the world that is
worth fighting for we have to connect as
humans only then we can surpass the
systems we establish that dehumanize
i got into filmmaking when i was a
teenager we found a camera and we were
just recording ourselves jumping from
garbage bins and stuff and now here i am
it was quite a ride
i hope that this film shows you that
when we connect as humans then we can
overcome the obstacles that are we
facing right now in this world thank you
very much
hello
oh wow i can't believe this hello do i
have very good news for you the gold
model narrative international goes to
your film
television congratulations oh my god no
you did a good job
thank you so much wow it's such an honor
hearing it from you as well thank you so
much for the wonderful news this means
really a lot to us hey guys how are you
gold we have gold
now
my name is murad
and my film is called television it's
the story of tala a young girl living in
a conflict zone with her father the
movie is about her finding a way to
watch television as it's her only window
to the world it is inspired by my
childhood of wanting to watch tv all the
time and wanting to see how the world
looks like i was just imagining what
would it mean for like thousands of
children growing up in these areas with
no reach for information
i want to tell stories that are critical
of society community and
tradition
if we don't make our voices loud for
ourselves and our causes who will
[Music]
thank you to the academy for this
incredible honor my biggest thank you
goes to the wonderful collective of
creatives that came together in making
this film i would like as well to thank
my mother family and friends and
everyone who supported us in the making
of this film our film is about childhood
and war zones it's about this vicious
cycle of broken dreams
i hope one day this cycle is broken
allowing dreams and innocence to prevail
again
thank you
this has truly truly truly been a day to
celebrate
and i have a way to make it even better
in 2022
next year let's do this in person
but until then we all thank the academy
and most of all our entrants and winners
for giving us something to hold on to
so thank you thank you so much for
having me and see you next year
[Music]
you